it looks very similar to an ellipse
except for your subtracting these two
terms as opposed to with an ellipse
you're adding but they both equal one
and they're both written in this
fractional form like you see here now
these are the two different forms here
and one thing that you'll notice is that
excuse me is that whichever term comes
first okay so if the x squared term
comes first it's the positive term that
tells you that the graph is going to
open in the X direction the horizontal
direction okay but if the Y squared term
is positive that tells you it's going to
open up in the Y direction the y axis
direction the vertical direction so
that's an important difference with
ellipses we were concerned with which
denominator was larger right that told
us which was the longer axis with
hyperbolas were interested in which one
is the positive term x squared is
positive it opens along the x direction
Y squared term is positive opens in the
Y direction up and down and of course
you can shift these graphs you know left
and right up and down and we'll get into
that too but the other thing I want to
show you is you know what do these a B
and C values all represent well the
distance from the center to the vertex
these points here are the vertices okay
that distance we call a and the distance
from the center to the full side we call
that distance C so very similar to what
we talked about in ellipses and I'll
show you what that B represents when we
get into the graphing we're gonna have
another equation we're going to use for
this one and that's C squared equals a
squared plus B squared just like
Pythagorean theorem and I wanted to show
you you know just to give you some
background like what a hyperbola
actually is so hyperbola is a set of all
points okay that when you take any point
on the hyperbola and you measure the
distance to one foci minus the distance
from that point to the other full-size
so P F 1 minus P F 2 when you take that
absolute value you always get 2a okay
that's the distance between these two
vertices okay so as you go further
further out on this hyperbola say you
take a point here this distance is going
to get longer but so is this distance
but the difference is always going to
stay the same it's going to be 2a okay
you don't need to know that you know too
much to graph these but just so you
understand
you know the background like what where
the formula comes from it's based on on
that but let's show you how to graph
these so x squared over 16 minus y
squared over 9 equals 1 this one is
centered at the origin so let's go ahead
and graph this one so the center is
right here at the origin the x squared
is a positive term that's the important
thing so that tells us going to open in
the x axis Direction left and right and
so I'm going to go for see the square
root of 16 4 to the right ok that's the
vertex and 4 to the left that's the
vertex so that's our a distance now in
the Y direction I'm going to go up and
down 3 square root of 9 is 3 that's our
B value okay and what we're going to do
is we're going to draw a dashed or
dotted or invisible rectangle here
through these points okay and what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
corners of this rectangle to draw our
asymptotes it goes right through the
center point and through the corners so
like this so right through the corners
the center and the other corner like
that and those are the asymptotes and
remember what an asymptote is is if the
graph gets closer and closer to that
line okay as it goes out like that okay
so it's approaching the asymptotes so
give us an idea about how wide our
hyperbola is or how narrow okay same
thing for over here on this side so it's
going like this it's going like this you
want it to get closer and closer you
want it to bend away from the asymptotes
you want to approach okay so the next
thing we want to do is we want to find
the coordinates of the foci
so we're going to use this equation here
C squared equals a squared plus B
squared and in this case this is a
squared this is a B squared so we have C
squared equals a squared plus B squared
these are already squared so that's 25
take the square root we get plus or
minus 5 now the foci are going to be on
the same axis where the vertices are so
if we're gonna go 1 2 3 4 5
there's our focus 1 2 3 4 5 there's our
other focus ok the other thing we want
to find are the equations of the
asymptotes these dashed lines that the
graph approaches so how do we do that
well
this one's gonna be pretty easy because
it goes right through the origin so
we're just going to find the slope we're
going to use the y equals MX plus B form
of a line the slope is rise three run
four okay and when this one here has a
rise of negative three over four so the
slope is going to be plus or minus 3/4
halves X 3/4 3/4 X plus zero right so
it's going right through the origin so
the B is zero so these asymptotes were
easy to find
okay all right so so far so good all
right let's take a look at this next
example so this thing will get a little
bit clearer as we do it ok so this one
the center is at negative 1 comma 3
the x-coordinate the center is grouped
with X the Y coordinates grouped with
the Y so negative 1/3 so that's going to
be negative 1/3 that's our center point
the Y squared is a positive term that's
important to recognize so that means
it's going to be opening in the Y
Direction up and down the vertical
direction I'm going to go up to square
root of 4 is 2 and I'm going to go down
2 okay so those are our vertices and I'm
going to go right 5 and left 5 so that's
in the X direction from the center so
that's 1 2 3 4 5 ok right about there
I'll just put a little point 1 2 3 4 5
I'll just put a little point ok so we're
gonna draw a rectangle okay through
these points okay and then we're gonna
draw our asymptotes they go through the
corners of the rectangle through the
center through the other corner okay
same thing here
through the corner through the center
through the other corner like this okay
and we know that the Y squared is a
positive term so it's going to be
opening in the Y direction so right here
I covered up the vertices but they're
right there and right there
okay and so the graph is going to go
like this and like this
okay so Pro Qing these asymptotes same
thing over here this one's gonna go like
this and like this okay the only thing
we have to find our the equations of the
asymptotes and the coordinates of the
foci so let's do that so the equation of
the
asymptotes okay let's do the full-size
first so we have C squared equals a
squared plus B squared okay a squared is
this one here B squared is this one here
so that's going to be 4 plus 25 so C
equals the square root of 29 plus or
minus
okay now the full sir on that major axis
okay where the vertices are located so
from the center since the center is at
negative 1 comma 3 I'm going to add and
subtract square root of 29 from the y
coordinate of the center because that
controls a vertical direction so I'm
going up square root of 29 and down
squared of 29 from that y coordinate of
the center ok now the equations of the
asymptotes let's use the point-slope
form of a line for these because we know
that the asymptotes are going right
through the center point we're going to
use point-slope Y minus y1 equals M
times X minus x1
ok the slope is rise to run 5 or a rise
negative to run 5 okay so that's going
to be plus or minus 2/5 X minus ok the x
coordinate which is negative 1 so that's
going to be plus 1 and y minus the y
coordinate which is 3 so that's Y minus
3 now you can write these separately Y
minus 3 equals 2/5 X plus 1 and Y minus
3 equals negative 2/5 X plus 1 and then
you can distribute and rearrange it and
put it into a slope-intercept form the y
equals MX plus B form but I've just left
it here like this just as a condensed
way of writing it but you'll have to see
what your teacher prefers and how you